[Music]
foreign
to another episode of the after show I'm
Nikki Novak your host and today we are
going to be talking about the Epic
black panther wakanda forever
amazing film answering some of the
questions uh that the film left behind
and talking about the future of Black
Panther and a bit about Marvel and for
this episode we needed somebody who is
the authority the expert who's written a
book about all of this caramel horn how
are you first of all let me just
introduce you you are a podcaster you
are a writer you are a host like I said
you wrote a book called Black Panther
Protectors of wakanda you also are the
host of Pop paranormal the horror
podcast on Travel Channel you are very
busy so thank you for joining us thank
you I'm so excited to be here and yeah I
I don't know about an authority but I'm
gonna do my best yeah I I there's so
many lovely things about this movie and
I can't wait to talk about it
come on
okay so before we move forward and I am
excited to talk to you because I know we
just chatted a little bit before we
started using you've seen this film
three times yeah um interest so
interested in your perspective but for
people who have not seen black panther
wakanda Forever This is a spoiler-filled
discussion so if you like that kind of
thing before you go see the movie then
you know stay with us otherwise leave
come back once you've seen the film
um let's dive into it the Tomato Meter
score on this film it's certified fresh
at 84 on the Tomato Meter the audience
score 95 and the critics consensus is a
poignant tribute that satisfyingly moves
the franchise forward black panther
wakanda forever marks an ambitious and
emotionally rewarding Triumph for the
MCU talk about a Triumph 180 million
dollars at the box office this week in
the highest ever for November over 300
million worldwide uh so my overall
question before we dive into the details
Karama how do you feel how did you feel
watching this film for the first time is
this they the filmmakers had their work
cut out for them obviously with the
passing of Chadwick Boseman Ryan coogler
saying he almost quit Hollywood
um didn't know if he could move forward
he had already written the story for
black panther 2 and then had to rewrite
the script and how do you feel overall
um do you feel he succeeded in his
mission
I do I mean here's the thing he had
such an incredible task in front of him
and I mean principal photography had
started before Chadwick passed like it's
just to have to do a course correct that
big and then do a course correct in the
middle of a pandemic in the middle of
like I know it's 2022 but folks remember
2020 like there was a lot going on and
what he was able to achieve
um I think he did an incredible job
um I've I've told people I've looked at
this movie three ways as a Critic as a
Marvel fan and as well like culturally
as a black woman and all three of us
um Love This Love This film and but
there is when you think about it even
the the critiques that I have it's like
what could he have done you know what do
you do and also it's the last movie of
phase five so there are certain notes he
had to hit because of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so I I think he did a
phenomenal job
I agree 100 I agree with the audience
score I think you know 95 96 97 98 99 I
would have been happy with I thought
that this was incredible I know I don't
you know I don't like to compare and you
know to other Marvel films or even black
panther but I think the beauty of what
they did is they didn't give a lot away
in the trailer like we I really had no
idea
where they were going with the story
where they were going with the film
um how they would pay tribute to
Chadwick and and weave it into the story
and how much you know how much we would
pay tribute versus moving the story
forward
um while being respectful and it was
just I love going into a movie not
knowing a lot and I love that they did
that and they allowed us to be surprised
and then the new worlds that they
created the underwater sequences uh the
talocan and that whole world I mean it
was just spectacular and you know that
first scene on the ship when you know
they ambushed that was like that
reminded me and I said this in my tweet
that it reminded it made me feel like
when I watched avatar for the first time
and you were seeing things on screen
that seemed ahead of their time in terms
of Technology like I don't know how Ryan
coogler pulled this off in terms of
something so stunning paying tribute
moving the story forward creating
something entertaining creating
something respectful but also
enlightening and lifting and made
everybody feel like one and that we were
all coming together it was such a
celebration in a sense
um I thought it was wonderful
um so we both absolutely loved it we'll
try to find things that we did we didn't
love about it as we were talking you
know as we put our critics hats on
if you can choose
favorite moments in the film and
highlights for you
oh gosh that's so difficult of course
the Chadwick you know opening or and I'm
saying Chadwick into I'm using Chadwick
and t'challa interchangeably when I say
that because if if you weren't crying at
the funeral you I was bawling at the
silent opening like the first time we've
ever seen the Marvel opening that is
just completely silent with just images
of Chadwick I was done I was done I'm
like I I don't know how no I'm gonna
make it to the rest of this movie but it
let you know we're we've gotten the
elephant out of the room but we're good
this is what we're going to be dealing
with and then when you see one year
later and you're looking at shuri and
then I realized I'm like this movie is
about grief you know this you know
shury's five stages of grief that we
watch her go through
um that was a huge highlight for me just
watching her Arc I thought Leticia
writes did an incredible job
to know cuerta
no more my God like I think some of my
biggest the highlights for me uh besides
seeing talukan like represented which
was gorgeous in and of itself was just
how they subtly also
explained who he was without using that
many words or that many words in English
for instance he said his you know when
you see him being born and he talks
about his mother and he realized that he
would Age very slowly it's very clear
all of a sudden that you know when you
see her as an old woman and she's
telling him I would like to be buried on
land and he goes to and it looks like
he's a child I'm like oh my God him and
Yoda are the same age he's 50 but he's
like he's 10. oh my God it's like so I
just thought it was like absolutely
um incredible the way they showed that a
lot of the uh moments of how he saw the
surface world were were painted on the
wall like there was a lot of symbolism
there I love that of course talukan and
then
you know Angela Bassett like who should
win all the things I take issue with the
fact that you know she was taken out her
character was taken out in the film but
we'll get there but yeah she embodied
this woman who has been had to bury her
husband bury her son is now running a
country and is not here for your excuses
like she was incredible and I thought
that scene between you know obviously
her and Okoye or okoya has lost Leticia
she doesn't know if her child is alive
or not that was one of the most profound
um moments in the film and then the last
highlight I would say is the fight
between Sherry and the more that was
Hardcore and there were moments that had
very little music sound effects yes but
very little music and I found that
really really uh powerful even though
the music in the score was absolutely
you know incredible but I I there were
so many moments there's just too many to
really count but those are the big ones
that come to mind for me I want to add
you touched on it but Okoye as my I I
loved Angela Bassett that Powerhouse
speech she gave have I not suffered
enough but when she fired her the
humiliation on her face yeah and how
much that position meant to her and how
much she was losing
hats off to deny as well right I mean
talk about a great you know tennis match
between two great actors and absolutely
and that power between the two of them
but
um I won't waste too much time because I
concur with all of your you know all of
the but I also liked shuri
um
and nemour sort of having those quieter
moments where he explained and you
touched on that too where he explained
to her his point of view because we've
always heard in the past oh I like a
villain that's misunderstood or that you
know you understand his motivations he's
not evil necessarily he has real reasons
for doing what he does and those make
the best villains never has that been
more apparent than in this film where he
brought me such a great actor he's so
much Charisma he brought me to so many
different places during the film to
where I understood him I wanted
everybody to just get along to where I
hated him when he then you know did what
he did and what what an introduction to
his character and cannot wait to see
more of him and how often that doesn't
happen with certain villains in any film
not not Marvel exclusively but so many
forgettable villains that I don't really
care and I've seen enough after one film
I'm like give me more of that because
that was incredible but also the World
building okay so let's talk about uh so
you mentioned that you loved leticia's
performance what did you think about how
they Incorporated her you know wearing
the suit and and and sort of taking on
the Black Panther mantle so to speak in
this film well now this is again this is
no this is the comic book Part of Me
Okay um they were in the comics a few
years ago a writer named uh Jonathan
Hickman created something it was for
t'challa but I think they applied it to
her in this case uh he gave him sort of
avatar The Last Airbender powers where
he could talk to all of his past
um the Black Panthers and that we saw
that in the in the first movie when
t'challa was speaking to tataka yeah but
The energy they also created in the
comics was that whoever needed to be
there when you needed them stepped up
and so I liked the fact that they kind
of brought that through she was going
through her stages of grief denial was
one of them she her going from grieving
to anger to acceptance when she's having
that conversation with no more
to then
you know absolute rage what that did to
shuri was fascinating and I also loved
how Winston Duke's embako and Baku
rather
Embrace his role as leader and counselor
to the now Queen region and I just
thought that was that whole Arc was
fascinating there's only one part that
did not work for me okay and it was not
in leticia's performance it was in the
editing and that was when she had him
dead to rights and you thought she was
going to kill him and she makes the
decision not to I don't think there was
a strong enough imp impetus there to not
kill him and I do think that if her
mother was still alive and she was like
in a in a you know uh injured or in a
coma or she could hear her mother she
did see her mother in her mind but she
just sort of popped up and she was like
oh okay I won't kill him I just felt
like that could have had a few more
beats and so that that to me was the
only thing that was a little bit off I'm
glad that he didn't die because I wanted
to know corta again but
um I do think that leticia's character
as sure I really took a very very
interesting art but I think at the same
time you can see her grieving to
Chadwick just under that Lair there were
some moments he just wasn't acting yeah
I think what's interesting too is in
Black Panther she was she represented
technology and in this film she is the
heart of the film
that's a tall order for an actress to
pull off she was also in the first one
we were introduced to her everybody fell
in love with her character right just
because she did bring the technological
side to things she had that great banter
with Chadwick and their relationship was
so integral to why that film worked it
was such a cute back and forth between
the two of them so to have her have to
move forward
um without him and create a new arc for
her character and a new like you said
you know the five stages of grief
she did a wonderful job and I hadn't
really thought about that moment you're
right about how why she what's her
motivation for letting him live it did
remind me a little bit of eternals
remember an eternal yes yes I remember
watching it and going oh this reminds me
of that moment that didn't quite work
but I didn't really think it did I mean
I had a few other issues
um little small issues with this film
that wasn't one of them but now wouldn't
you point that out I'm like oh yeah
you're right you're right I'm an insane
I'm glad she did
um so moving forward Angela Bassett is
getting a little bit of Oscar talk for
this performance she should as she
should it's a it's it's a tough category
this year this is a really great year
for female actresses both in lead and
supporting
um but you believe I mean it's just
obvious that you feel like she should be
nominated for this performance well it's
funny you know the funny thing about the
Oscars is I always feel like the people
who win so often best actress should
have gotten it for like another movie
but they give it to them in the years
that they you know
like Angela Bassett has done so many
incredible incredible films like What's
Love Got to Do With It Like come on so I
I think that um
yes there is some tough competition but
the amount of screen time that she got
and the amount of moments that they let
her do her thing if you notice when she
was at the UN and they were trying to
you know talk around her and tell her
like her you know what wakanda should be
doing for the rest of the of the western
world as well as when she was in those
chambers with
um Okoye you know letting her know that
I'm sorry you are no longer of service
and even when she was on the beach
trying to plead with her child to get
through her grief all of those moments
if you notice they were close-ups and
there were medium shots it was very rare
that they went wide because they you
they wanted the camera just loves this
woman and she's so incredible at what
she does okay so we talked a little bit
about
um to knock but let's let's just dive
into him a little bit deeper
um thoughts on his character overall in
the writing of of his story and where
where do you want to see him going you
know in future in the future I thought
he was written beautifully I also I I
love the fact that he was introduced in
silence and in darkness like that was
the more that was whipping that
helicopter around by its you know and
you didn't see him you didn't see him
when uh when when the and the thing I
loved also about the talukana and
talukani that when they
started singing that siren Song and
people started jumping off the boat I
was like oh my God they're using lore
from the sea and giving it to indigenous
people like every single thing that
you've ever heard now Sirens mermaids
everything I'm like that's out the
window it's all from the telecon it's
all them and
um but then when that helicopter is in
the air because remember
it takes off and they all just look up
no one is pressed they just kind of look
it up and then it starts whipping around
and you don't see why it was thrown into
the sea that was his introduction and
then you see him speak when he comes on
land
um to meet Queen ravanda and it was
really funny he's like oh wow it's
beautiful here the air is so lovely like
I just love not just the lines
um but the way tanakawarta really
embodied
the role because when shuri says to him
you know these are Mesoamerican
artifacts
but these are your things like how old
are you
and it really it really came to you to
see like this man they look at him like
he's a God because he ages as slowly as
Wolverine like he could be like hundreds
of years old and it's just fascinating
how he embodied that in just a few
scenes and I also loved his his snark
his little his
um conversation that would be amusing
sometimes like when Sherry's like I'd
love to see you know the rest of your
kingdom he's like okay you could go down
there on that but you'll be crushed or
you can wear this suit like he had these
moments of Comedy that I thought were
absolutely fantastic his concept of
timing his
moments and there are things that he did
just
he is such an incredible actor even with
his facial expressions and that is a a
an example of a really not just
well-trained but well versed actor and I
and I loved all of that with him and
everything he said he said listen this
is what I'm here to do this is why we're
doing it if you do not obey me this is
what's going to happen and he stayed
true to his word how did you feel about
the underwater sequences the world that
it built
um I've heard people criticize a little
bit the VFX that they thought they were
a little bit murky it wasn't as bright
as black panther what did you how did
you feel about that I do think that the
choice to use a different uh and I don't
have I do not have the name of the DP in
front of me but the choice to have the a
different DP this time did make a
difference I did not want this to be
bright and pink and purple like Aquaman
I didn't want to see that oh but I I
don't know I didn't no that's and then
not to criticize Aquaman is brilliant
and it's just a different movie yeah
it's just a different movie but I
definitely and here's the thing the
first time I saw it I it was like a
screener theater and you know sometimes
the screen of theaters the sound is
better than the the screen itself so I
was like all right let me see it again
but I've seen it three times and I'm
still getting Game of Thrones like why
is it so dark work in certain areas and
so I really wish that some parts of that
were brighter I don't know if that's a
VFX choice I feel like that's a color
correction choice and and that's a
decision that was made by Kruger and his
team
um and I think uh you know I have an
editing background and I definitely can
tell you that sometimes the screens that
are being edited on and that people are
seeing things on are the best quality in
the world but the scenes that are
delivered you know when you see a movie
it's never going to be look as good as
it did on that uh screen that the
director was looking at so I I
definitely agree I love the concept of
telecon I loved how beautiful it was and
I love the fact that he had vibranium to
bring his people a son that he had
charged vibranium in the ocean I love
that but I really do wish we were able
to see more of the people and that it
wasn't so dark I do know that they're
represented in that big Throne scene
they're supposed to be thousands of
people but I didn't really get that
until they were at war with wakanda and
then I then I'm like oh there are a lot
of of telecon okay yes when we first
dove into the under yeah I felt like it
was as expansive as it was I was
expecting it to be a little bit more and
then my brain of course goes to Avatar
and what are we going to see you know
how is it going to be different and I
couldn't help it sort of compare
um and I think maybe that's why a little
bit it made me aware of the VFX only in
the underwater sequences because I think
because I've seen a preview of Avatar in
3D and and I my and and I know the
timing of them coming out around the
same time kind of made me think of it
um but the talocam people in general
um such a beautiful culture and this is
again you think about how Brian started
this film and having to deal with the
grief and then to create
these new fighting styles new worlds new
cultures the way he introduced them
that's why this film is so brilliant and
let's get a little bit into award season
talk because
of all of the potential nominations in
my opinion the one that should be
nominated is Ryan coogler for director
oh absolutely that is the one above
everything else that I would hope for
absolutely I think that Ryan coogler as
a director
um co-writer
all of that I absolutely think he should
win I also think that um
Hannah beekler who won last time for
production design she should win
definitely definitely costume design
yeah who's e Carter again please give
her flowers again because those plumes
those feathers oh my God even the new
um suits even those tiny tiny details
like Okoye who is General of the dorm
Elijah she has a gold band around her
neck and her and her bracers are gold
when she stripped of that those gold
bands go to IO so she is not it's a
visual thing they never say it she is
now the head of the Dora
um and then of course I'm I'm you know
because I wrote a book about them full
disclosure I'm a little partial to the
durable as a but I definitely think that
that's where a lot of the costume design
stuff you know them when the midnight
Angels came in that stuff was absolutely
stunning so I really really think that
costume design should win production
design should win but I'm I'm in
complete agreement with you at minimum
at minimum Ryan cougar should win for
best Direction and possibly best
co-writing what about best picture
should it be nominated I do think it
should be I do think it will be I don't
think I don't know if it'll win
because personally I think well one I
think the first movie should have won
but superhero movies it's so hard for
them at the Oscars it really is I do
think that there is still a bias against
fantasy and comic book films that they
are not high art they are just you know
part of a big advertising machine and
I'm not saying that that latter part
isn't correct but it doesn't mean that
they can't be executed beautifully
um I would love for it to be to win this
picture I hope it gets nominated
not sure if it'll happen just because
I'm jaded I'm Jaded by the academy it's
interesting because this is the first
year there's been a couple obviously
black panther was nominated and a couple
superhero films have been nominated in
the past couple of years but I feel like
because of top gun Maverick because of
the Batman because of this film
um you also have Elvis that some people
are saying and that's a blockbuster film
as well that you're gonna have for the
first time
a lot of what you consider people
consider not high art films being
nominated this year and this could
potentially be the year that one of
these films does break through and win
and I think in terms of popularity
people tuning in I think there's a wave
I think the last few years it was a you
know it was a lot of independent films
smaller films
um more High art films and now people
you know it's like the pendulum always
swings now it's gonna I feel like it's
gonna swing back to I would love to have
that Titanic moment from 1999 I think it
was where you had the highest ratings of
all time because you had audiences that
cared about the result and cared about
the films that were nominated and that's
not a reason to be nominated these films
should be nominated on I think they were
the best films of the Year quite frankly
and from what I've seen I've seen almost
every award season filmed now so far so
uh okay and so just to wrap up the award
season talk a cinematography and VFX do
you think they deserve nominations and
and hair and makeup
um hair makeup definitely yeah
cinematography it was good but I still
think I still feel
and I understand why this this this
movie was very cool and much physically
darker in color than the first movie The
First movie was very warm remember that
you know the fight scenes with tataka
and I'm sorry with killmonger and
t'challa that water that was very warm
very orange this was very cool very blue
and very dark
I I it's a matter of preference I'm not
sure if if I would give it best
cinematography hair and makeup
absolutely costume design absolutely
Ludwig Gordons and score again oh yes
when all of the music when you hear when
they come when the telecon come up out
of the water that siren song that was
chilling you know even the music that we
hear
um
within telecon and the chance and
language that they're using there like
all that research again and then of
course he brought back babamal for the
funeral March and a lot of the the music
that we heard was in wakanda I thought
it was absolutely fantastic even when
they went to Haiti and Cape Verde he
found
pieces of of not just indigenous but
local music and instruments to use so I
I just think live with gorenson's score
should absolutely win so this is the
time that I'm going to ask you to put of
the three of you that watch this film
and to talk about any negatives that you
found in the film or anything that you
thought maybe wasn't in line with what
you were hoping for
um so yes my critic hat it's so funny
because I've had this conversation with
so many people I think my credit cat
would first say
it did not probably need to be two hours
and 40 minutes which was 30 minutes
longer than the and then the first film
the first film was two hours 15 minutes
um I think there were moments that could
have been shorter that could have been
given to other things or just shorter as
a whole
as you know as a fan I loved the length
and I loved that it was you know as long
as it was and I got to sit with some
things before we ran off and looked at
something else but I the critic in me
was like this I could have shaved about
20 minutes off of this film
um I think uh I mentioned earlier my
little issue with shuries
resolution towards the end that is also
tied to another problem I had with the
film and that was uh the death of
ramonda I it I understood the gravitas
that they were going for but
unfortunately it's sort of a comic book
Trope to kill a woman to get everybody
to do all the things and I and I was
kind of
I was kind of annoyed by that
um at the same time I was really
devastated that it was you know Ramona's
character but also in terms of the film
as a whole
and there's precedence for this in the
comics Ramona could have been in a coma
like she could have she should have
obviously had same scene same you know
saving of reread but put her in a coma
let her spend the rest of the you know
movie trying to recover trying to regain
Consciousness and then you have a reason
for sure to change her mind because all
of a sudden she hears her mother's voice
now awake through her comoyo beats
telling her shuri this is not you we
don't want to do this you do not want to
kill someone this is not what you want
to do
and at the same time somebody has
mentioned to me but she probably would
have wanted to take out you know no more
for you know taking her child but I felt
like that would have been a really great
moment it would have been a fabulous
moment to see her in Haiti with her
grandson later I mean we they do they
are in scenes together earlier but we
don't know it's you know her grandson at
the time yeah but I you know I just felt
that there were so many missed
opportunities for the third and fourth
acts of this film because she was not
there
um so that to me
duh that that bothered me and I also
think that
I think as a whole also we spent so much
time mourning t'challa that when she did
die it was sort of like yeah she's dead
I just processed that she's gone and now
we're looking at her Casting and now
okay we're all moving to the Jabari
lands and I was like I
she deserved a little bit more time than
that you know and I and so that also
kind of rubbed me the wrong way a little
bit so I wish there was little more time
spent wish Ramona lived wish there was
more time spent on her like a little bit
more of in her recovery
um and then also yes a little bit more
time spent in talocon with the people uh
but I know that's really hard to
coordinate you know 300 people
underwater holding their breath so uh
you know hats off to the people who were
able to pull it off and give us what we
got but I think those are my
biggest criticisms of the film
everything else and again I've seen it
three times everything else I'm I'm okay
with I really am yeah I I keep agreeing
with you but I I thought it was a touch
too long as well I did sort of think
afterwards there was a few places I saw
that they could have shaved a little bit
maybe like you said two hours 15 minutes
but Ramona I agree and the reason why it
bothered me is because we are mourning
to challah but we are also mourning
Chadwick and there was a reason why that
had to be in the story obviously the
actor passed away so then to choose to
kill another character in my opinion
took away a little bit from paying
homage to Chadwick
because that's a story point that you
chose to kill her you didn't have to you
had to with t'challa exactly and so I
felt like it took like the film should
be a tribute to his death within the
character and the actor and I feel like
that took away a little bit from it and
I want to see more of her I mean you
don't let her she has this these great
scenes and then we I want to see where
her character would have gone moving
forward yeah I just that was a that was
a choice that I just really didn't agree
with and still doesn't quite sit right
with me if we're not gonna get another
black panther until you know
2028 or something it's possible that she
just said you know what I I do not want
to be you know beholden to that at the
same time
there we find out at the end of the
movie that she did know her grandchild
so there's there's room to have a story
I mean look what they did with black
widow there's room for a story in
between of
you know grandmother you know spending
time with her grandchild t'challa and
there's room for flashbacks and there's
room for conversations and other scenes
so it might not be the last that we see
of her but I I was
I was kind of sad about that I want to
go into talking about some of the
surprises of the film and it kind of I'm
tying it into my biggest issue with the
film and that was the killmonger scene I
did not think I was so excited because
you first see him from the back and the
camera pans around and for a second I
was like who is this going to be I
didn't realize it was going to be him it
was a great reveal but then the air was
let out of the tires he is such a
dynamic actor and it was such a
um
wishy-washy scene in my opinion they
didn't give him a chance to shine and
you go from going it's killmonger to
going oh that was it that was his Cameo
I feel like he had to be disappointed
with it how did you did you have an
issue with it tell me I'm wrong but I no
no I don't think well here's the thing
was it too short yes
um but I do think when we see the uncut
scenes or the scenes that were left on
The Cutting Room floor we're going to
see a longer monologue out of him
and
it doesn't surprise me I mean first of
all I I did like the way they brought
him back I just wish we saw more of him
I did like the way that he he his energy
had to be what she needed to come back
and cross that threshold of I need to
take charge I need to do what I need to
do because that was not an energy that
she was used to exercising she was
always you know kid sister in the lab
and she had to do a lot of sure he had
to do a lot of growing I liked the fact
that when she came back she brought part
of him with her
yes that part was cool yes that part was
cool I just wish the scene or their back
and forth was longer I wish she came
back and didn't get in the mantle right
away this is what I mean by like some of
the lengths like I would have taken some
of the time from some of some other
scenes that I felt were not necessary
and put them into back into a
conversation with her or her having
dreams and having to see him again and
him going like you still doubting me you
know and and like a a battle within her
mind with him so I do agree that I wish
they were there were there was more
killmonger more Michael B Jordan you're
never going to see me ask for Less
Michael B Jordan the same
ever yeah but that's the thing like when
you hear people talking about the film
you would have expected it would have
been like a big Twitter thing like oh
killmonger was back Michael B Jordan the
big reveal and no one's talking about it
because I think it was a little bit
anticlimactic unfortunately and I think
maybe part of it was the way it was also
shot
just yeah I definitely I definitely felt
like that entire scene was done
post posts like we've all heard about
you know uh let's Tasha Wright being
injured on satin like having this
shooting stopping for a while and then
having to start again I definitely felt
like this is one of the scenes that were
shot very late in the schedule
um because it did look and feel so
different than the rest of the film yeah
like he was working on 20 other projects
and said I'll give you a day exactly but
he was on trees exactly like before I
cut my hair for creed let's shoot this
yeah he was actually at home when he
shot it
exactly welcome around his living room
yes yes he completely was okay let's
talk about the big reveal Prince
t'challa
I mean what a moment that when I tell
you I bald well one of the reasons why I
also balled was that uh my boyfriend's
Haitian I've got friends and family who
are Asian so I was like the king is
Haitian like that's the first thing that
went through my head and all if for if
anybody's looking at what Hades been
going through like if you pay attention
to the news
this this is so beautiful for children
and for you know and so but I also love
the fact that with all of the uh
the rancor surrounding you know hashtag
recast t'challa and a lot of people
being very angry about t'challa not
being in this film and and not recasting
an adult character and we want to
challenge we should not have a movie
without t'challa it's like they hurt us
but they could weren't going to say
anything you know because there have
been rumors about that child being in
this film for like two years so I I
think I don't think he's a recent
addition I think he was scripted in from
jump I also like I mentioned earlier it
was so lovely seeing the movie again and
noticing that he is who's in the school
that welcomes his grandmother when she
comes to visit and he's the one that
speaks to her and he's like oh you want
to see the teacher right and so like he
knows there's like their little secret
and I just thought that was so beautiful
I also thought they cast the actor
beautifully because if Chadwick had a
child he would look like this actor
um yeah and it also leads into what I'm
saying earlier about the next phase of
the MCU we're going into the Young
Avengers we're going into the young
version and if anybody's curious there
were alternate universes were in the
comics where it's inshallah had a child
and there was a child in Missouri that
was an Avenger so it would make perfect
sense to me if in two or three years
this seven-year-old you know or it it
they age them up you know we jump
forward in time and we now have a
teenage t'challa that is coming
to the states and and avenging with Ms
Marvel and everybody else I find I find
that fascinating
um but at the same time it also sets up
multiple things which have also happened
in the comics there have been a time
that there has been someone on the
throne as king or queen and and that the
person within the Black Panther suit was
not king or queen they were simply the
protector of wakanda as Black Panther
and even in the comics t'challa's father
dies when he's very young and he does
not take the mantle right away there is
a regent in his debt his uncle is in
power so they're setting up a lot of
things that I think are fascinating
because now we do have a world of
wakanda we have someone who is the
protector as black panther we have
someone that's going to be sitting on
the throne it looks like that's in Baku
and now we have this Future King
and and the choice that he's not going
to live in wakanda he's going to live in
Haiti he's going to live outside the
country until it is time for him to take
the throne I find fascinating let's dive
into you know the direction and the
focus of this movie I think the MCU
phase four has been criticized this is a
mature a more mature film in a sense
than maybe some of the series and and
movies that we've seen in phase four
um and then of course whenever you have
that you're going to have people that
are going to criticize right so how do
you respond to that
phase four to me and also I feel like
somebody from the from uh Disney might
have said this but I don't quote me on
that but I do feel that phase four is
all about reflection so it started with
black widow and it ended with wakanda
forever two characters that died yes the
the actor that played t'challa passed
away but it just in terms of what we're
looking at the where everything in phase
four has been a reflection of end game
of things that happened in the previous
phase and it's sort of lining us up for
a new generation
um every single uh movie and story I get
the concept of people thinking that
phase four felt disjointed a pandemic
will do that you know Civic unrest will
do that so I I don't think that that's
um yes it is a criticism yes you can
agree with it but I also again look at
what we were in and look at how we
weren't going to be able to see movies
in theaters and have a lot of stuff
shifted to streaming and so they also
have their work cut out for them because
the majority of what they were trying to
create was supposed to all have
hit the screens by now and we should
have already been tumbling into the next
phase and here we are in November 2022
just hitting you know black panther
which is now the you know the end of the
phase that's a really good point that
now we're just you know we would have
moved forward already had it not been
for the pandemic and so I think
sometimes people's
lack of patience has to do with that I
mean look
phase four you didn't have any of the
Avengers movies that kind of were the
thread because you are setting up this
new world a lot of the characters that
we came to know and love from The
Avengers films and you know past phases
have moved on have you know so you need
that reset you need to hit the reset
button and you need to build that world
and I in feige I always trust I believe
and you know we're not going to get
Avengers until phase six like you said
this would have come sooner in the
timeline had it not been for the for the
pandemic and people forget that right we
always kind of want to call that a blip
in a sense in terms of but it does
factor into what happens in film it does
and also I feel like we have seen the
Avengers but people don't realize who
they're looking at meaning yeah they're
setting up another generation so I feel
like the previous phases have been the
older Millennial Gen X reliving their
childhood seeing all of these comic book
characters come to life and that's how
fandom drives you know a lot of the
marketing it's like oh this is a comic
and I or a character that I grew up with
but now what we're being introduced to
is all of these new Avengers like even
in the comics there was a young Avengers
and uh Kate Bishop Hawkeye was in there
we miss Marvel what wasn't but there's
no reason why she couldn't be but
everybody's kid was introduced like even
uh Captain America Winter Soldier
um Elijah Bradley you know he becomes
Patriot in the comics we also have a new
Captain America like even though people
like I don't understand what we were
doing here you are being introduced to
all of the new characters that I think
are going to be made up making up the
next phase I mean look at Heimdall as a
kid Axel you know so Thor love loving
Thunder or the god butcher's daughter is
the goddess of love love like so we I
think people are
so used to looking for where is the
Steve Rogers where is the Tony Stark not
realizing that okay but now we have
um Iron Heart now we have might have a
kid Loki you know and I think you know
on top of everything else we're gonna
get X-Men because not only was Miss
Marvel introduced as a mutant but to not
cuerta's character no more
said very plainly I am a mutant so we're
about to get uh X-Men in the next phase
so I think what it is is that I think a
lot of people are waiting for the main
course not realizing they just got the
appetizer no you're a hundred percent
right and they want that familiarity
right they want to see the stuff that's
been familiar to them the characters
that have been familiar to them but if
you're going to move forward into a new
phase you need that moment where you get
to know these new characters so I'm
curious now as you are talking how you
felt about uh phase four films overall
like which ones you loved and and did
you appreciate which ones you
appreciated the most and which ones did
you take issue with if any it's funny
um we were just talking about the
seriousness of films and I felt the
internals was very serious
um and I I it did not feel in line that
was the first movie to me that I
actually felt not quote unquote in line
with the rest of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and then I realized okay we're
hitting no notes here we're hitting a
type of a tone here and then I include
the Disney Plus shows in the MCU you
know in my sort of purview because they
hopped in and out of it another very you
know serious serious uh look at even
Captain America Winter Soldier there
were some heavy themes in there you know
Moon Knight his mother's abuse like I
was like oh we're going in yeah you know
so I actually think that seriousness is
one of the things that
um I liked that thread that was
throughout I I think my favorite show
probably is still one division just
because of the execution with all the
different TV shows and not knowing that
it was her mind and things like that I
think that and
um most of Captain America Winter
Soldier uh were fun to me Loki is also
my favorite but I'm a doctor who fan and
it felt very juven
um so that's the other reason why so the
geek in me really we really enjoyed it
but of all the movies of phase four I'm
I'm probably gonna say that zhangji and
wakanda forever are probably my
favorites
um
and
just because of how big they were and
how World encompassing and also the
graphics and the effects and everything
and I'm a big fan of people who aren't
born with superpowers but get access to
either something magical or Tech or
something that gives them access and so
you they have to reconcile their real
world issues and problems with their
Newfound Powers so I think both of those
movies represent that and I think those
are my favorites we're in line with it
completely in line with the TV shows
face four completely in line but you
know it's funny as I reflect on phase
four I think initially like when I saw
eternals I remember going to the
premiere and being like when I look back
I want to watch it again now I'm curious
because I think it's that initial shock
again of not having the familiar or know
where it's going or seeing the thread I
think we'll see the thread as we move
forward they're laying the groundwork
like you said but I I appreciate even a
Multiverse of Madness I appreciate the
different tone that I think when people
reflect on it you know a few years from
now they'll look back with a different
appreciation where they'll see how it
sort of had that Standalone feeling
um and when one last question before we
wrap up should coogler direct Secret
Wars what are your thoughts on on that
I think he absolutely could but I again
what he went through because I've seen
some of those interviews where he talked
about like almost quitting Hollywood
I don't know if he's got it in him I
think he's going to sit down for a
minute they're gonna have to give him a
whole lot of money
um
yeah I think I think I think he's gonna
take a break I would love it if he did
it I think it would be fantastic if he
didn't but if he took a break and then
came back and did a Young Avengers I'd
be there for here for that too yeah yeah
and he has said you know in terms of
black panther three and that he is going
to take a beat and he's gonna sort of
see how people respond he's gonna let it
digest and he's gonna you know he had
they obviously have ideas uh but in
terms of being the most you know the
russos have said they're not you know
they're not touching it in terms of who
is the most competent
maybe not willing but able
it has to be him yeah I think it should
be here I don't think it should be Taco
YTD I I love it but I don't want comedy
on that one I want like and here's the
other thing we're gonna get now again I
I would love it if there was a a dorm
Elijah Story coming to Disney plus the
only thing we can say is that there is a
show coming to Disney plus starring
tonight Guerrera yeah as a koye will it
be called the koi will be called mortal
wakanda we don't know we don't have
absolute cooperation on that yet I want
him involved in that you know what I
mean and then maybe his you know love
for staying in the Marvel Universe will
and if they treat him really well that
he'll give us a secret Wars but I I
would really love it if it was if it's
not the Russo Brothers I would love it
if it was
um Ryan and I I just it can't be taken
now I I need him to take a seat like so
yeah I don't think I I don't but I don't
see it I don't see it it's a certain
style it's going to have to have a
certain you know somebody with the that
has that World building and that ability
to sort of Juggle a lot of balls and I
haven't seen that yet from Thai foreign
did with
eternals was lovely and lyrical but I
don't think that's what secret Wars
needs this has been such an incredible
episode your passion thank you and your
knowledge has just been
marvelous
I know so many people have done it but
it just came to my head
um so thank you so much for giving us
your time and wisdom and if you can give
yourself a plug and remind everybody
where they can find you sure I'm Karma
aka the Blurred girl
t-h-e-b-l-e-r-d-g-ur-l all over the
Internet
um I'm still on Twitter for the time
being until it implodes
um and then I'm also in Tick Tock and
Instagram please check me out there and
I'm also the co-host of Pop paranormal
the horror podcast that's all about
horror movies and yeah if you get a
chance and you really liked the movie
please pick up my book Black Panther
Protectors of wakanda a history and
training Manual of the door milage it's
all about all those beautiful women that
you saw in the movie and their weapons
and their skills and I was lucky enough
Marvel let me write their origin story
so I'm just so excited to be able to
contribute to like canon in like a teeny
tiny way
um but yeah if you can pick it up I'd
appreciate it well congratulations on
your book Thank you again it's been such
a joy talking to you and thank you all
for joining us and we will see you on
the next episode of the after show bye
foreign